emmy how are you i'm so good how are you
i'm doing great um
after the
big cliffhanger of season two the
opening of season three doesn't
disappoint
from your point of view like what do you
love about coming back to this show
season after season
i think with every season we continue to
top ourselves i think we we introduce
even crazier and more extravagant
scenarios to put these characters
in and through
and the writing is so good and the the
family dynamic is so good and so i feel
like every season we're just you know
carving out a bigger and better
understanding of this family and how
they operate and and how they work and
function and i just think that that's so
exciting that we just get to go a little
deeper with every season with these with
these characters
the headlines for this are saying that
you know this is the best season yet is
that something that you feel
while you're in the midst of putting it
together or are you just focused like on
what you need to get done
i think it's a little bit of both but i
do feel like this season felt really
special um and that might have been
because of covid and because we were so
isolated and we you know we were all so
focused on this thing and and wanting to
make it as safe as possible and as and
as as good as possible given the
restrictions of of the covid protocols
but i i don't know i think if it um
steve blackman in the writers room i
think they just really kind of have
honed in
on this the the world of the umbrella
academy and i think i think
yeah it does feel like it's
it's really special and it's really kind
of found itself completely now uh you
and elliot have always had a very
um
uh
the relationship between your characters
has always been so strong in the back
and forth and the ups and downs what was
it like working with elliot to put
together this story of victor coming out
it was amazing i mean elliot is one of
my closest friends and i adore him so
deeply and i
you know was was very much a part of his
journey um through his transition and
and still am and i'm so
just
endlessly proud of him and
it was just such an honor to
to it is such an honor to have that
trust
from him in real life but then it was
also such an honor to be you know the
character that goes alongside his
in this moment which for television has
never happened before a a character and
an individual have never transitioned at
the same time on screen and off and i
just think it's so special and i just
feel so lucky and so grateful to be a
part of that and to to to
walk alongside him on that journey
awesome emmy uh thank you so much for
the time congratulations on like this
wicked wicked season oh thank you
yeah of course hope see you soon